[Music]
four years ago i
uploaded a video explaining how
littlefinger might have caused robert's
rebellion
it was well received and well-liked
theory
now that house of the dragon is coming
in just over a year
that theory if true might be more
significant than ever before
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood
volume 1
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
in other words it covers events from
aegon's conquest to the dance of the
dragons
that's fire and blood vol 1 house of the
dragon will start with a build up
towards the dance of the dragons
and early seasons will cover the dance
itself later seasons however will be
based on george r martin's yet
unfinished fire and blood volume 2 book
the yatan released fire and blood volume
2 will continue from where part 1
ended with rhaenyra targaryen's son
aegon iii's reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion that tended
targaryen dynasty
in this video i'm going to tell you a
theory of mine that i came up with four
years ago in which littlefinger calls
robert's rebellion
and ultimately the end of the targaryens
since the first season of game of
thrones we have learned that peter
baelish is a cunning
unpredictable and ruthless manipulator
of court politics
as varys observed himself lillyfinger is
a grasper from a minor house with great
skill at befriending and eventually
manouring powerful people
his treatment by the talisman he was a
young man and he is near
death at the hand of brandon stark and
bittered him against both the talis and
the starks
littlefinger had orchestrated the entire
war of the five kings
the war in which tens of thousands of
soldiers since civilians died
little fingers we can call it the genius
plan back in season 1 was to kill jon
ren with the help of jon's own wife
which he did
and then to make ned stark as the new
hand of the king whereupon he helped ned
to figure out who joffrey's real father
was
littlefinger knew that it would lead
honorable ned to reveal the truth to
everyone else
which led to king robert baratheon's
death as well as to ned stark's
beheading
which started the war of the five kings
littlefinger also made it seem like
lannisters tried to kill bran when in
fact it was his doing
long story short littlefinger threw the
seven kingdoms into the state of chaos
from which he personally benefited let
me highlight one varys quote regarding
littlefinger
littlefinger was born with no lands no
wealth no armies
he's acquired the first two how long
before he has the army
perhaps you laugh but i know him better
than most
and this is the truth littlefinger is
one of the most dangerous men in
westeros
and let me also say that this
conversation between varys and elena
took place in the fourth episode of the
third season
meanwhile lillyfinger married liza tully
video of floor jaina reign of the vale
who poisoned
jon on littlefinger's order and
therefore peter baelish became the lord
protector of the vale
as varys said littlefinger became very
powerful man with
lands and wealth and even managed to
provide himself an army that he's
basically commanding
which he made possible by influencing
the young lord robin
the new lord paramount of the veil peter
baelish also did all he could to set
sansa as queen in the north he betrayed
ned stark in order to set up a fight
between wolves and lions
poison geoffrey joffrey's own wedding
with the help of olenna tyrell
to save sansa and then handed her over
to boltons
all in order to turn the north against
the boltons and to give him an
opportunity to lead the knights of the
veil
that he is commanding by manipulating
young lord robin
which he provided by killing robin's
father and mother
all of this in order to set sansa as the
queen in the north
convinced that it would lead to marriage
between him and the new queen of the
north
which would provide him norton army and
thus one step closer to the iron throne
as he saw in the season 6 finale in the
battle's aftermath littlefinger
approached sansa in the godswood
and admitted that his goal is to sit on
the iron throne with her by his side
with her as his queen however despite
him being arguably the most cunning and
the most intelligent player in the game
baelish is not incapable of making
mistakes and his plan to manipulate
sansa failed when the old seeing bran
stark returned home
with all of this being said let's see if
there's any evidence that peter baelish
beside orchestrating a major civil war
in the seven kingdoms known as the war
of the five kings
also orchestrated the great civil war
among the great houses of westeros
known as the war of the usurper or more
popularly robert rebellion
as we all know robert's rebellion
resulted in the collapse of the
targaryen dynasty and the ascension of
robert baratheon to the iron throne
i know that most of you are probably
confused at this point and are probably
wondering
why would have and how could have he
orchestrated robert's rebellion well
it's actually pretty simple
and there are two reasons revenge and
benefit
and in the following minutes you will be
introduced with how exactly he might
have done it
peter's father served well under lord
holster tully
and through their good relationship
hoster agreed to
foster his son peter at riveran which
was a great honor for house baelish
peter went to riverand when he was 8
years old and there he befriended
hoster's daughters kathleen and liza
tully
while their brother edmure mockingly
nicknamed him lillyfinger
the nickname that would stick with him
through his entire life
peter became obsessed with catelyn but
she never returned his affections
eventually when she was engaged to
brandon stark
ned's older brother heir to lord of
winterfell and lord paramount of the
north
peter challenged him to a duel praying
then defeated baelish easily
nearly disemboweling him in the process
but kathleen begged brandon to spare his
life
the maesters were able to save baelish
and he eventually recovered
but he was left with a deep scar running
from his stomach to his collarbone
a token from brandon that baelish would
carry with him
after this baelish was cast out of
riveran
and returned to wale later brandon stark
who had been on his way to river and to
bed catelyn tully
was enraged due to false information
about prince rhaegar targaryen's
abduction over his sister lyanna
and instead the river and hero to king's
landing immediately
to demand rehgar's arrest and punishment
aries the med
king arrested brandon for treason and
eventually killed him and his father
rickard in a horrific
and unjust way which led to houses
baratheon stark and
rain rebelling against the iron throne
now in my opinion those false rumors
about rehgar's abduction over leona that
basically started robert's rebellion
were started by none other than peter
baelish himself
as we learned in later seasons of game
of thrones rhaegar did not kidnap lyanna
but they rather loved each other and
went away together
however it's still unknown why they
decided to live without the word
knowing this could start a war knowing
how kind and noble rhaegar and lyanna
were
it's also hard to believe they would let
the seven kingdoms as well as their own
families burn for their love
on the one hand we have brandon who at a
time had been on his way to riverrun to
red catelyn tully
while on the other hand we have lyanna
who was in the riverlands when she
departed with rhaegar to the tower of
joy
when you take a close look it does seem
possible that littlefinger spread the
false rumors of rhaegar abducting lyanna
in order to prevent the wedding between
his beloved kathleen and brandon stark
as well as to seek revenge against
brandon who almost killed him sometime
earlier now before i go any further let
me just show you one clip
from the third episode of the very first
season that's going in favor to this
theory
i thought that she'd be safest one of
several such establishments i own
you're a funny man huh a very funny man
ned
ah the starks quick tempers
slow lights as you can see eddard was
furious when littlefinger brought him to
her brothel
believing that he is a victim of a bad
joke but kathleen intervened when ned
attacked littlefinger
whereupon littlefinger said the stark's
quick temper
slow minds could it be that littlefinger
spread false rumors about rhaegar's
abduction over lena stark
knowing that it would lead quick
tempered brandon stark who was also
known as the wild wolf
to do something honorable and stupid at
the same time
which would result with brandon not
continuing his travel to riverrun to
head catlin
but instead to ride to king's landing
and eventually die
which is exactly what happened could it
be that this little fingers quote about
the starks was actually a foreshadow
of ned stark's death because just as
brandon ned stark had a quick temper
but slow mind to figure out
littlefinger's manipulation
in the seventh episode of the first
season littlefinger said
there's one thing he learned from losing
his duel to brandon stark
he learned that he will never win on
their honorable way
but will rather as he set himself
manipulate them to provide himself
everything he wants which at first was
catlin tully and revenge against brandon
stark
there's a high possibility that
littlefinger did spread false rumors
about rhaegar's kidnap over lyanna
in order to prevent brandon stark's
marriage with his beloved catelyn
since he knew brandon had a quick temper
which instead of thinking twice about
his next act
resulted in him riding to king's landing
immediately
and demanding justice from the mad king
which resulted
just as littlefinger wanted with
brandon's death
there's one more fact that is going in
favor to this theory
which is confirmation of peter baelish
knowing that rhaegar did not
abduct lyanna which the fourth episode
of the fifth season almost certainly
confirmed
there's a scene in which peter finds
sansa in the crypts of
nfl paying her respects to her deceased
family members
peter recalls about how rhaegar
targaryen chose sansa's
aunt lyanna which started robert
sibelion against the targaryen family
on which sansa replied with confirming
that rhaegar did choose her aunt
but against her will on which
littlefinger did not reply
but he didn't even have to his face
expression was more than enough
littlefinger had known the truth how
many tens of thousands had to die
because rhaegar chose your aunt
yes he chose her and then he kidnapped
her narrator
how did littlefinger know the truth in
the first place to be able to twist it
around and spread false information you
might wonder
well there are many possibilities
littlefinger like varys is known to have
spies everywhere
so that's one possibility the other
possibility is that he himself saw them
run away
the third more complicated possibility
is that littlefinger
intercepted leona's message or letter
that was meant for her brother brandon
in which she wrote that she and rhaegar
are in love and will spend some time
together
making sure no bad assumptions arise to
start a war
but littlefinger simply burned the
letter and spread the false rumor
i'm convinced that littlefinger spread
the false rumors about
rhaegar's abduction over lyanna to
prevent brandon from marrying his
beloved kathleen and to get brandon
killed
while also starting a civil war from
which he would benefit
as after the war he joins the small
council he did always say that chaos
benefits him
house of the dragon airs in 2022 and
since the later seasons will cover
robert's rebellion i'm looking forward
to find out why liana had not left a
simple note for her family
that could have prevented the death of
her father and brother as well as the
deaths of thousands of soldiers and
innocent people
they died during robert's rebellion
there's a possibility that lyanna wrote
a note
but it was simply handed over to the
wrong person and was never read by the
starks
i'm convinced littlefinger caused
robert's rebellion for revenge and
benefit
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace